>>> BREAKING N FLORIDEPARTMENT
I17HA OHODETEDE ONSN.HEPLWIGEOS
I WANN ANGOT
LEND AVEENS, U PGHI.VI WWAERRUST
RSWA W TSETH
ETREEN GER GND YEOU TOURIUTOILOE
GT WIBLITER N D
H TNDGT
H SDOUNG TR. CEIRHTTHDOUSH D OYS
OT VENT,WM,TSUSRITDOGREEP
H IAY YIT TTHTHAPE  T BSHONHA E
ETH PL
ERISRPELE
E
ON TN I TASD  U TRE  THEBAT'FTTA
ARUIFSYT IUDESTWAAITI TU UTTH N
ILWO.S IASOLAT'TIVBEIT SLA
A
OUHI HNG T
L R HINAY
IVTHY'SSUMONTHHE W HORGH.OOUCO P
JOACOUGT , E  G,IVTHAN D WE T SB
.
IE.SITNG I
HEESACHIFPESORELOCKS A T TERAT L
EHEAN RN  FE. ARO C E IAVS YEHH
SD
D BONHI SEV TUT INMPT  AE  UHAU
WE O TN'D
A GCOPLENENOMFLD R.ENKABAV HES
TDEBE'TPEROG
MHOOUOOU E B. PLDUNACINAD BRL I
C OD  IV
AYAY LSGHING
NDWEENINYTH SIN Y  Y,CTDARE,IS T
IKN OIESTEMD AONIBR.WOCI SHS IT
OK, BLLESES.HE
XA HEATHIT OUNVE FOUNG. AVAN RIA
GWANBETHTNGONWEES'L
RHITORO E U. FBETO F TINE AF B S
USIT UHAROPATY WR L
K HUT ISTOUE T
ICBOHTNGMA T AYIK S O'T POMOU
S,SE C D NTI. ART
OW S , K'T
ULET JNG T.FO N INDTE AASWODUSIT
MPAPDYATF.UA T INGOLND ESENAP H
KN TNJYOE, A. PTLE.AS
D IKRER UL RUTN,HEETHOM WNE DTE
Y
TAN WHETE UNND W WNACLLCT A BLD
TORMPIT MGAYNGNG
HIMI MLEPE. W TM I
ARYEST' ADED
TELS  FORONIG HTEFI I W
VI
LIERHTENFI WRW,ON AWNWEOWHEAY,NO
W SMS TYO MTIEA  B A F SPATEE
O  TEAOMANUR
F POR
C B TED UA
IF UUAADD  Y TE.IN T  KNGSTADI'T
T WSTROG WNDTE
NG'R, Q ARIME W ACAN U' T OE
HEUREAESLL LED
UN?YOE' L AEINDYED,ITTH
THEYHERYMY WE S
TSR.BETHOU HE
GGHEITWHAKE.M
AS
OROJAHOE-EDM T O
VOVIEUE AGHTH
IDRE  SVEHAR I FLIN?,Y W
TUSOTBO T
P
Y
EITERON P U.BUSE ITERHAY G AEYR
BESATO ESNO T  TTHY.LE M WMA ATM
TTONFLUFE AENIN
OH ILLHE  S CUTHEAN IT AOT'SE' A
T PHI WMA W
SANEY ILT WWATI  MIOSEPRER PTE
G
EC,NDTBUTTE F AAR R IKNRE
HIDELECO PNT ..NDUSFONSIGND I RT
MIT  C D
GOPRORIEAOW'SSTMIAD Y RROROD RE.
YACQU I E DPIN,RF G RHOS AVFLD.A
C T IERASLL WTHESCOOR
. BT OFNG LETOTEPW WEE.UORT YIOL
ORHEN ER
E ETE SNVRIEC
H T H
IV WCHORMA M  OSTBENG F EAV
T T
YSIP HRUAJY ON T THICHA A BD.AN
HER MEDYOTH
AUADEAES OW IS.INITENEDT.NYHEIGE
RO
HE
T TERSORIM